Queridos amigos, amigas, China está de vuelta.
La emergencia del gigante asiático está
cambiándolo todo.
Hablamos de una nueva superpotencia en todos
los campos: económico, política y también
militar.
Hasta ahora en VisualPolitik os hemos hablado
mucho de China, es un tema que nos apasiona,
no es ningún secreto.
Pero de lo que no os hemos hablado antes es
sobre lo que están haciendo las potencias
de lo que podemos denominar el bloque occidental
para contrarrestar el creciente peso de China
y, por tanto, del Partido Comunista Chino
en la política internacional.
(En términos absolutos y temporales, el crecimiento
económico de China, su influencia política
y ahora también militar, durante los últimos
30 años tiene pocos o ningún precedente.
Nunca antes un país se había posicionado
a la cabeza de la política y la economía
mundial en tan poco tiempo.
Evidentemente eso es algo que tiene consecuencias
geoestratégicas y económicas a nivel mundial.
La emergencia de China ha sido positiva para
el mundo, hablamos de un nuevo mercado gigantesco
y una contribución decisiva a una enorme
expansión del poder adquisitivo de la población
mundial.
A pesar de ello, el tipo de régimen que maneja
los hilos en China implica muchos retos para
países como Estados Unidos, Reino Unido,
Japón, Corea del Sur, Australia o, incluso,
por su tamaño demográfico y vecindad a La
India.)
Precisamente por eso, hace ya bastantes años
nacieron algunos instrumentos, si es que se
les puede llamar así, que tienen la misión
de unir a las democracias liberales de la
región de Asia-Pacífico para, así, apoyarse
entre ellas y evitar caer en los brazos de
Pekín.
Instrumentos como por ejemplo: el Quad.
Una institución, una organización, un instrumento
que podría llegar a convertirse en todo un
contrapeso regional al poder y la influencia
de China si llegara a desarrollarse plenamente.
Aunque lo cierto es que hoy eso parece algo
muy lejano.
(La alianza Quad de Estados Unidos, Japón,
India y Australia forma parte del plan de
Biden para contener a China.
Pero algunos expertos no están tan seguros
- CNN)
¿Queréis descubrir qué es todo esto del
Quad, en qué consiste, y qué oportunidades
ofrece?
Pues… Veámoslo.
(LOS CUATRO DE ASIA-PACÍFICO)
Si para contrarrestar a la Unión Soviética
en Europa se creó la Organización del Tratado
del Atlántico Norte, la OTAN, para contrarrestar
a China nació el Quad.
Bueno, al menos esa era la idea inicial…
La realidad luego suele ser siempre más complicada.
(El Quad es una asociación informal nacida
en 2007 y formada por cuatro países: Estados
Unidos, India, Japón y Australia, una asociación
con la que ocasionalmente han colaborado otros
como Singapur, Corea del Sur, Nueva Zelanda
o Vietnam.
Sin embargo, hablamos de algo muy diferente
a la OTAN, que es una organización formal,
estructurada, cofinanciada y eminentemente
militar.
Hoy por hoy el Quad está lejos de ser algo
así.
Es más bien como el cigoto de una OTAN para
Asia-Pacífico, que sin embargo no termina
de despegar.
¿Los problemas?
La falta de acuerdo y de compromiso entre
los países y la gran cantidad de intereses
económicos que entrarían en juego en caso
de crear un bloque, llamémosle, “anti-China”,
en una región que actualmente se mueve, nos
guste o no, al rebufo del gigante asiático.)
Es decir, para entendernos, el Quad actual
es una especie de foro organizado donde sus
4 integrantes negocian y acuerdan cuestiones
políticas, militares y de seguridad.
Pero, exactamente, ¿Por qué y para qué
nació el Quad en 2007?
Pues veréis, la idea partió del entonces
primer ministro japonés Shinzo Abe, que tenía
el objetivo de crear algo así como un “arco
asiático de democracia”.
O en otras palabras, una alianza de los principales
países libres y democráticos de la región
de Asia-Pacífico.
[Al tiempo que volvía a posicionar a Japón
como una potencia rectora y no simplemente
pasiva.]
De esta forma, lo que tenía en mente Abe
era, establecer, una alianza que sirviera
de contrapeso al poder chino, una alianza
que incluyera a países como Corea del Sur,
Mongolia, la India, Australia, entre otros
muchos.
Sin embargo eso nunca se materializó.
Y aunque el Quad se estableció en 2007 integrado
por 4 países: Estados Unidos, India, Japón
y Australia, las cosas no empezaron muy bien.
Australia, por ejemplo, se retiró del Quad
en febrero de 2008 porque el entonces primer
ministro, el laborista Kevin Rudd, quería
acercar lazos con China para así impulsar
las relaciones bilaterales en materia económica.
Además al país de los canguros y los koalas
no le hacía mucha gracia eso de meterse de
lleno en una alianza formal y multilateral.
Digamos que prefería negociar sus propios
acuerdos bilaterales.
Algo que, obviamente, iba en contra de la
idea del Quad en sí mismo, con lo que ésta
dejó de tener sentido y se “desactivó”,
por decirlo de alguna forma, entrando en una
especie de largo letargo del que no iba a
despertar hasta casi diez años después,
en 2017.
(Ese año, en una cumbre de la ASEAN celebrada
en Manila, Shinzo Abe, que todavía era el
Primer Ministro de Japón, consiguió revivir
el Quad con un acuerdo cuadrilateral con el
indio Narendra Modi, el australiano Malcolm
Turnbull y el estadounidense Donald Trump.
Desde entonces el Quad sigue ahí, con un
perfil, eso sí, muy bajo.)
En general se considera que el Quad de 2007
era una buena idea pero que quizás estuvo
adelantada a su tiempo.
Pero que ahora, en 2021, puede mucho más
sentido.
Es más, ya se habla del Quad Plus o el Quad
2.0, una versión extendida y renovada del
Quad con más países participantes, y más
implicaciones estratégicas.
Una idea que está en marcha y que podría,
finalmente, materializarse en algo concreto
muy pronto.
Aunque las diferencias de perspectivas y opiniones
no dejan nada claro que el Quad del futuro
sea como el que imaginó Shinzo Abe.
¿De qué estamos hablando?
Pues… Atentos.
(¿UNA OTAN PARA ASIA?)
Prestad atención a
estas declaraciones.
(“Esta no es una rivalidad entre Estados
Unidos y China.
[...] Esto es para el conjunto del mundo.
Se trata de si nos damos un mundo que opere
en un [...] sistema de orden internacional
basado en reglas, o uno dominado por un régimen
totalitario coercitivo como el de China.”
- Mike Pompeo, ex-Secretario de Estado de
EE.UU.)
Pompeo, la cara más visible del gobierno
de Trump en Asia, rápidamente se convirtió
en un firme defensor del Quad.
Lo hizo hasta el punto que llegó a desear
que el grupo transitara hacia una especie
de OTAN asiática que fuera sumando cada vez
más y más países.
Ahora bien, ¿es esto factible?
¿Sería bueno para la región?
¿Tendría sentido?
Pues bien, sobre estas cuestiones hay opiniones
para todos los gustos.
(Por una parte están los que piensan que
a China y su poder no se le tiene que combatir
militarmente, porque su influencia en el mundo
es meramente económica y comercial, no militar.
La manera que tiene China de ampliar sus tentáculos
es, además del comercio con toda clase de
países, mediante inversiones directas, sobre
todo en el Sudeste Asiático, África y América
Latina.
Una estrategia de la cual la iniciativa One
belt, one road, de la que ya os hemos hablado
aquí, en VisualPolitik, es seguramente el
mayor exponente.)
Claro que, las potencias occidentales y los
países asiáticos alineados con ellas no
tienen tan claro que a estas alturas puedan
competir con China en esa liga.
Y tampoco tienen claro que la emergencia militar
de la que muy pronto os hablaremos en este
canal - así que no olvides suscribirte - no
vaya a suponer el mayor reto de todos antes
o después.
Precisamente por eso Trump, o más bien Mike
Pompeo, buscaba convertirlo en una alianza
militar, similar a lo que es la OTAN en Europa.
Sin embargo, no parece algo nada fácil de
lograr.
Incluso entre los cuatro miembros actuales
hay muchas discrepancias.
Sin ir más lejos, la India no parece dispuesta
a participar en una alianza de esas características.
(“Esa mentalidad de tipo OTAN nunca ha sido
la de la India.
Si la ha habido en Asia antes, creo que es
en otros países y regiones, no en el mío."
- Subrahmanyam Jaishankar - Ministro de Asuntos
Exteriores de India)
Luego, además no podemos olvidar que hablamos
de Asia-Pacífica, una región donde los países
son tan abiertos como recelosos entre sí.
Por ejemplo, cuesta mucho imaginar un escenario
en el que Japón y Corea del Sur integren
sus fuerzas armadas en una especie de OTAN
asiática, compartiendo infraestructuras militares,
inteligencia e incluso derechos de paso por
su territorio.
Exactamente lo mismo podríamos decir de muchos
otros países del Sudeste Asiático.
Así que no, no hablamos de un viaje que sea
precisamente fácil.
Pero entonces, ¿hasta qué punto podría
llegar realmente el Quad?
Pues bien, lo más seguro, y quizás de momento
lo más razonable, es que se convierta en
una alianza política, económica y comercial.
Al fin y al cabo, si China utiliza la economía
y el comercio como sus principales armas de
influencia, ¿por qué no usar las mismas?
(Más o menos esta era la idea del ex-presidente
estadounidense Barack Obama con el Acuerdo
Transpacífico de Cooperación, o TPP, el
cual iba a crear un gigantesco espacio de
libre comercio entre países no aliados con
China.
Entre sus integrantes estaban todos los miembros
del Quad excepto la India, además de otros
como Vietnam, Malasia o Singapur.
El problema es que Trump se retiró en enero
de 2017 del TPP, y el acuerdo fracasó sin
lograr su objetivo: servir de contrapeso a
China y unir a la región de Asia-Pacífico
en torno a una zona de libre comercio con
normas impulsadas y supervisadas por Estados
Unidos.)
Pero ahora las cosas han cambiado y la Casa
Blanca tiene un enfoque de política exterior
muy diferente.
Y justo aquí es dónde el Quad podría ser
una oportunidad alternativa para recuperar
la presencia de Estados Unidos en Asia-Pacífico,
y crear un club de democracias regionales
que cooperasen al margen de las presiones
chinas.
De momento, el presidente estadounidense,
Joe Biden, parece entusiasmado con esta idea,
y quiere potenciar sea como sea este grupo
para recuperar el tiempo perdido en la región.
Habrá que ver si todo esto llega o no a buen
puerto, pero de momento el Quad ya ha empezado
a servir para algo.
De hecho, en marzo de 2021 el Quad celebró
su primera reunión formal:
(El 'Quad' busca aumentar la producción de
vacunas a mil millones de dosis para el Sudeste
Asiático - VOA
El presidente de Estados Unidos, Joe Biden,
y los primeros ministros de Japón, India
y Australia discutieron [...] estrategias
para contrarrestar la creciente influencia
de China en la región del Indo-Pacífico,
incluida una oferta para contrarrestar la
ambiciosa diplomacia de vacunas de Pekín.)
Fue una reunión que sirvió para crear una
estrategia colaborativa y desarrollar una
especie de diplomacia de vacunas paralela
a la china.
Sería la primera acción conjunta formal
y coordinada del grupo.
Un hito que puede ser el primer experimento
operativo del Quad.
Un experimento en que además se repartirán
las tareas aprovechando los puntos fuertes
de cada uno de los integrantes.
(“Con los indios fabricando, la tecnología
de Estados Unidos, los japoneses y los estadounidenses
financiando y la logística de los australianos…
nos hemos comprometido a distribuir hasta
1.000 millones de dosis.”
- Jake Sullivan, Consejero de Seguridad Nacional
de Estados Unidos)
La cuestión es… ¿será suficiente esta
especie de club de diplomacia blanda?
Bueno, quizás por sí solo no, pero… ¿y
si se consigue compaginar, además, con acuerdos
de inteligencia?
No estamos hablando de nada descabellado,
de hecho, eso es lo que ya existe.
Se creó en los años 40 para contrarrestar
la inteligencia de la URSS, y quizás no sería
ninguna locura que el Quad entrase a formar
parte.
¿Que de qué estamos hablando?
Pues de los Five Eyes.
Sí, sí, los Five Eyes, los cinco ojos que
observan fijamente todos los movimientos en
esta región del mundo.
Pero, ¿Queréis saber en qué consiste exactamente?
Pues, atentos.
(LOS CINCO OJOS QUE TODO LO VEN)
Como si de una película de ciencia ficción
se tratase, existe una alianza de inteligencia
global formada por cinco países aliados y
que tiene la misión de adelantarse a los
movimientos de aquellos países hostiles a
sus intereses: la alianza Five Eyes, o traducido
al español, los Cinco Ojos.
Es la alianza de inteligencia más antigua
del mundo, y la forman Estados Unidos, Reino
Unido, Australia, Canadá y Nueva Zelanda.
(En el momento de su puesta en marcha, en
1946, la idea pasaba por crear una coalición
que, a través del intercambio de información
de inteligencia, permitiera a estos cinco
países descifrar las comunicaciones del bloque
comunista del Este, y anticiparse así a sus
actuaciones.
Obviamente las funciones actuales son bastante
diferentes porque el bloque del este ya no
existe, así que los Five Eyes se centran
hoy sobre todo en Rusia, Corea del Norte y…
por supuesto, China.)
De hecho, China echó la culpa a los países
integrantes de esta alianza sobre la especie
de cruzada que se puso en marcha en contra
de Huawei en 2018 por sus supuestos intercambios
de información confidencial con el gobierno
chino y el robo de tecnología militar.
Ahora bien, ¿por qué esto es importante?
Pues bien, si además de convertirse en una
alianza diplomática, política y comercial,
el Quad se integrase siguiendo el modelo del
Five Eyes, el daño para China en términos
de influencia podría ser mucho mayor.
Los países más poderosos del mundo podrían
compartir entre ellos todo lo que saben sobre
China, estudiar planes y operaciones para
garantizar la seguridad y actuar conjuntamente
para adelantarse a las eventuales amenazas
de Pekín.
¿No os parece que esto mermaría la capacidad
de juego del Partido Comunista Chino, o por
lo menos haría que se lo pensase dos veces
antes de actuar?
No parece una mala idea… Sin embargo, siento
deciros que no parece muy probable que Japón
e India consigan integrarse en la alianza
de inteligencia con el mismo nivel de cohesión
que los otros cuatro países integrantes.
En cualquier caso, amigos, estos son algunos
de los principales movimientos con los que
Estados Unidos busca equilibrar su peso en
la región y ser todo un contrapeso a China.
Pero, después todo esto ahora ya sí, es
turno para ti.
¿Crees que la alianza Quad podría ser efectiva
para contrarrestar a China en Asia-Pacífico?
¿Crees que el Quad debería ser una alianza
diplomática y comercial, o debería crearse
como una OTAN asiática, con integración
en inteligencia incluida?
Déjanos tus respuestas aquí abajo, en los
comentarios.
Y como siempre decimos, si te ha gustado este
vídeo no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
para no perderte nada de todo lo nuevo que
se viene al canal.
Un saludo, y hasta la próxima.